Це український танк ще радянської розробки - Т-64.
Солдати ЗСУ жартома запитують німецьких журналістів,
а чи не привезли вони сучасні "Леопарди".
Радянські танки - це все, що вони мають.
Вони воюють. Якось так.
Ми не можемо обирати. Що є - те є.
Цей танковий батальйон веде бої під Бахмутом,
де ЗСУ намагаються прорвати російські позиції
на південних та північних околицях -
українці там повільно просуваються вперед.
Проблема в тому, що вони очікували, що ми підемо
зараз у контрнаступ.
Тут, на цьому напрямку, трохи рельєф поганий,
щоб нам штурмувати, бо в них там трохи висоти кращі.
Як тільки танкісти повертаються з завдання,
механіки розпочинають технічне обслуговування бойової машини.
Цьому підрозділу пощастило більше за інших -
вони з початку війни втратили лише половину танків.
Цей, судячи з його броні, пережив уже багато.
Трошки пошкрябано, але це таке…
Головне, що є броня і все. От, бачите, повивертало також.
Тут було все вивернуто. Замінили і до бою.
Броня стара, але боєздатна.
Ці танки радянських часів значно легші за свої західні аналоги.
Це робить їх більш маневреними, але знижує захищеність екіпажу.
Ключовим елементом радянської розробки є
автоматична система заряджання. Це означає,
що танк може швидко перезаряджатися,
але це таїть у собі небезпеку.
У разі детонації боєзаряду гине весь екіпаж.
Це стало проблемою для росіян, адже вони воюють
на таких самих танках. ЗСУ за допомогою
західних протитанкових комплексів зуміли знищити
чимало бронемашин з екіпажами всередині.
"Джавелін" та NLAW - це страшна річ.
Це ж треба ще попасти. Це треба, щоб була ця зброя.
В них (росіян) її немає.
Українці й досі цінують Т-64.
Танк був розроблений у 60-х роках у Харкові.
Загалом він ще підходить для ведення бою.
Танковий парк дістався Україні після розвалу Радянського Союзу.
І хоча на українські позиції і прибули західні танки,
зокрема "Леопарди", для багатьох підрозділів Т-64, як і раніше,
залишається основною бойовою машиною.
Але в нього є і суттєві проблеми.
Одна з найбільших - швидкий перегрів двигуна.
Влітку навіть коротка подорож може бути непростою.
В умовах нестачі "Леопардів" надія ЗСУ -
на трофейні російські танки.
Росіяни переважно використовують більш сучасні
моделі порівняно з Т-64 - а саме Т-72.
Мені більше подобаються трофейні, ніж ці.
Вони швидші, новіші, не так часто ламаються.
Їздимо, працюємо. Бувало, що виїжджали,
по три конвеєри працювали.
Виїхали, розрядили з противника, повернулися,
завантажили й поїхали ще раз.
На цих кадрах замаскований трофей ЗСУ.
На броні навіть видно букву Z.
Проте воює цей танк вже за Україну.
Перша ж партія американських танків "Абрамс"
має прибути в Україну лише на початку цієї осені.
У відділі закупівель армії США кажуть, що
це не просто танки, а повний пакет, який йде разом з ними.
Тобто і боєприпаси, і запчастини,
і паливне обладнання, і ремонтні засоби.
Втім, за даними видання Politico, перша партія
налічуватиме лише від шести до восьми танків.
Загалом же США планують відправити в Україну
31 танк, що відповідає українському танковому батальйону.
США також працюють з європейськими союзниками
над створенням потужностей для ремонту танків Abrams
та іншої важкої бронетехніки, переданої Україні.
Німеччина ж ще навесні передала 18 сучасних бойових
танків "Леопард 2". Поляки надали - 14,
іспанці і шведи - по 10, а також інші союзники.
Загалом щонайменше 85 машин.
Точне число з міркувань безпеки тримається в секреті.
Крім того, в Україні вже є і старіші моделі німецьких
танків - Leopard 1. Загалом Берлін схвалив експорт 178 цих машин.
Першою ж з "танкової коаліції" союзників
погодилась надати ЗСУ основні бойові танки
західного зразка Великобританія.
14 одиниць Chаllenger 2 вже в Україні і готові до бою.